Narrator: TONIGHT WE CELEBRATE
PRODUCTS PROUDLY MADE
IN AMERICA.
WE'RE THE AMERICAN DREAM.
IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
WE DIDN'T INVENT FIRE,
WE PERFECTED IT.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
I THINK IT'S BRILLIANT.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
ALL RIGHT,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I THINK WE OUGHT TO
PARTNER TOGETHER.
I'D DO THAT DEAL.
NO, NOT YOU, KEVIN. LORI.
HA!
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
I WANT TO BE MRS. WONDERFUL.
Narrator: ...OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THERE'S ABOUT $700,000
WORTH OF DEBT ON THE BUSINESS.
[ ALL GROAN ]
JUST LIVING ON DIRT
RIGHT NOW.
WHY AREN'T YOU
MAKING MORE?
I'M NOT SURE.
YOU CAN'T MAKE UP YOUR MIND
ABOUT MAKING UP YOUR MIND.
I WOULD GO NUTS!
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
♪♪
FIRST INTO THE TANK
ARE ENTREPRENEURS
WITH AN EASIER WAY TO MAKE FIRE.
-OOH.
-OH.
FIRE.
HELLO, SHARKS.
I'M KONEL BANNER.
AND I'M FRANK WESTON,
AND WE'RE FROM RIVERDALE, UTAH,
AND OUR COMPANY
IS INSTA-FIRE.
AND WE'RE SEEKING $300,000
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
NOW,
SINCE THE DAWN OF TIME,
MAN HAS SEARCHED FOR
AN EASIER WAY TO START A FIRE.
CAVEMEN
BANGED ROCKS TOGETHER.
THE NATIVES
RUBBED STICKS TOGETHER.
EVEN DANIEL BOONE
USED FLINT AND STEEL.
SO, WE DIDN'T INVENT FIRE,
WE PERFECTED IT.
NOW, INSTA-FIRE
IS THE SAFEST
AND YET MOST POWERFUL
FIRE STARTER,
CHARCOAL BRIQUETTE
LIGHTER,
AND EMERGENCY FUEL
ON THE PLANET.
WATCH HOW EASY IT IS.
YOU JUST TOUCH IT
WITH A MATCH OR LIGHTER,
AND YOU SEE IT LIGHTS
SIMILAR TO A CANDLE.
NOW, ONCE IT'S LIT,
NOW IT WILL TAKE
A 20-
TO 30-MILE-AN-HOUR WIND,
FLOATS AND BURNS RIGHT ON WATER,
BUT YET, MORE IMPORTANT,
IT WON'T BURN OUT
THE BOTTOM OF YOUR GRILL
WHEN YOU USE IT
TO LIGHT CHARCOAL.
BUT YET IT'S SO SAFE,
IF I DO NEED TO PUT IT OUT,
I CAN PUT IT OUT
EVEN WITH ITSELF.
INSTA-FIRE IS AS EASY
AS ONE, TWO, THREE.
SIMPLY OPEN THE POUCH,
POUR IT OUT, LIGHT IT,
ADD A LOG,
AND YOUR FIRE'S GOING.
NOW, WITH CHARCOAL,
IT'S JUST AS SIMPLE.
MOST PEOPLE USE
A CHARCOAL CHIMNEY.
THEY TAKE NEWSPAPER
AND STUFF UP UNDER THE CHIMNEY.
AND IT'LL
GET THEIR COALS GOING,
BUT WHEN THEY GO
TO DUMP THEIR COALS,
THE ASH BLOWS ALL OVER
THE BACKYARD.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY'VE STARTED THEIR NEXT FIRE.
WE'VE ACTUALLY ELIMINATED THAT
BY DEVELOPING A CELLULOSE POUCH.
SIMPLY JUST LIGHT
BOTH SIDES OF THE POUCH
AND PLACE YOUR COALS RIGHT OVER
THE TOP OF THE POUCH.
HAVE YOU EVER WONDERED
HOW YOU'RE GONNA BOIL WATER
OR COOK YOUR FOOD
IN AN EMERGENCY?
EVERY DAY.
[ LAUGHS ]
INSTA-FIRE SOLVES THIS
PROBLEM, AS WELL. OKAY?
ONE CUP OF INSTA-FIRE,
USING NOTHING ELSE,
WILL BOIL 4 CUPS OF WATER
IN ABOUT 10 MINUTES.
NOW, WHETHER YOU'RE HIKING,
CAMPING, BACKPACKING, GRILLING,
RVing, ATVing -- ALL GOOD FIRES
START WITH INSTA-FIRE.
DO YOU HAVE SAMPLES
FOR US TO TOUCH?
WE DO ACTUALLY
HAVE SAMPLES FOR YOU.
HERE'S OUR FIRE STARTER.
-THANK YOU.
Herjavec: I THOUGHT
WATER DIDN'T PUT OUT.
WATER WILL PUT IT OUT.
IF YOU POUR IT OVER IT.
IT'LL ACTUALLY FLOAT AND BURN
ON -- ON WATER, OKAY?
HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THIS?
SO, THIS OLD MAN, I MET HIM AT
A MOUNTAIN MAN RENDEZVOUS.
A MOUNTAIN MAN RENDEZVOUS?
PEOPLE GO, COME FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD,
AND THEY DRESS UP LIKE
A MOUNTAIN MAN.
AND WHAT DO YOU DO?
OH, THROW TOMAHAWKS,
AND, YOU KNOW --
IT'S A REENACTMENT OF --
OF THE MOUNTAIN MAN ERA.
ALL RIGHT. SO YOU GO TO
THE MOUNTAIN MAN --
SO, I'M -- I'M AT
THE MOUNTAIN MAN RENDEZVOUS.
I SEE THIS OLD MAN,
HE'S BURNING A ROCK.
AND I THOUGHT,
"WHAT THE HECK?"
THE OLD MOUNTAIN MAN
HAD THE IDEA?
HE KIND OF
HAD THE IDEA.
I SAID,
"LET ME DEVELOP IT."
IS THE VISION FOR THIS --
IS IT AN EMERGENCY PRODUCT?
IS IT A FIRE STARTER?
WHAT -- WHAT IS -- WHERE ARE
YOU GONNA SELL THE MOST?
ALL -- ALL OF THE ABOVE.
THERE'S THREE DIF--
WE'VE ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED
THREE MARKETS.
WHAT ARE THE THREE MARKETS?
WE ACTUALLY STARTED WITH
THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS MARKET,
DOING AN EMERGENCY FUEL.
WHICH IS THOSE BUCKETS.
WHICH IS THE LARGER BUCKETS,
THE EMERGENCY FUEL.
GOT IT. OKAY.
OKAY.
AND THEN -- AND THEN, UH,
WE -- WE KIND OF MOVED INTO
THE FIRE STARTER
AND THEN MOVED INTO
OUR CHARCOAL BRIQUETTE
LIGHTER.
HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN DOING THIS?
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS NOW.
-SEVEN YEARS.
-OH, WOW!
AND WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
UH, TO DATE,
IT'S $2.1 MILLION.
THAT'S ALL?
I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED.
WHAT WERE THEY LAST YEAR?
LAST YEAR,
WE WERE $378,000.
OH.
THIS YEAR,
WE PROJECT $850,000.
WHAT -- WHAT DO YOU
SELL THESE FOR,
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
SO 18 1/2 CENTS FOR THAT UNIT
IS WHAT IT COST US.
EVERYTHING, ALL IN?
ALL IN...
EVERYTHING ALL IN.
PACKAGING,
LABOR, EVERYTHING.
18 1/2 CENTS?
18 1/2 CENTS.
AND WITH
A PACKAGING MACHINE,
WE CAN GET IT DOWN
ABOUT ANOTHER NICKEL.
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
SELL IT WHOLESALE AT $74,
AND WE RETAIL AT $149.
ANYBODY CAN MAKE IT.
IT'S NOT PROPRIETARY, RIGHT?
OH, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
NO,
IT'S -- IT'S PATENTED.
Herjavec: WHAT AM I MISSING?
YOU GUYS ARE GREAT.
BEEN DOING IT FOR SEVEN YEARS.
IT WORKS.
THERE MUST BE A COMPETITOR
OR SOMETHING THAT --
NO, SO, WHAT'S HAPPENED IS
WE DIDN'T GET THE WORD OUT FOR,
OBVIOUSLY, FOR SEVEN YEARS,
RIGHT?
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF,
THAT'S WHEN
WE REALLY GOT INTO RETAIL
AND NOW THE HOME DEPOT, SO --
THE HOME DEPOT, MEIJERS, ACE,
TRUE VALUE, CABELA'S --
MOST OF THOSE HAVE COME ON
IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
WHY DO YOU THINK IT'S WORTH
$3 MILLION?
YOU ASKED $300,000 FOR 10%.
YOU'RE SAYING THE BUSINESS
IS WORTH $3 MILLION TODAY.
SO, WE WILL DO
$850,000 THIS YEAR --
WHAT WILL YOU MAKE ON THAT?
$238,000.
AND WHAT DO YOU PAY
YOURSELVES?
JUST $36,000.
$36,000 EACH?
-YEAH.
-YEP.
JUST LIVING ON DIRT
RIGHT NOW.
AND YOU'RE RUNNING -- YOU'RE
RUNNING EVERYTHING, RIGHT?
-LITERALLY.
-[ LAUGHS ]
YEAH, YEAH.
WE WEAR ALL THE HATS.
YOU'RE SELLING
A $1.29 PRODUCT.
I MEAN, IT'S -- IT'S TOUGH.
YOU GOT TO DO MASSIVE VOLUME.
YOU'RE SAYING THE BUSINESS
IS WORTH $3 MILLION.
YOU'RE PRICING IN
EXECUTIONAL EXCELLENCE TODAY.
WHEN YOU'RE IN GROWTH MODE,
IT'S ALL ABOUT
WHAT IT'S GONNA BE WORTH
IN THE FUTURE.
Konel: CORRECT.
BUT $300,000 --
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY FOR 10%.
SUCH A SMALL AMOUNT OF EQUITY.
YOU'RE VALUING THE COMPANY
AT $3 MILLION TODAY.
EVERYTHING HAS GOT TO WORK
REALLY WELL
FOR ME TO OWN 10%
AND GET A RETURN ON IT.
I'M OUT.
APPRECIATE
YOU LISTENING TO US.
GUYS, I -- I LOOK AT THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN A SPACE
I SORT OF KNOW
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
UM, YOU GOT A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD OF YOU.
THE ONLY WAY
I'LL DO THIS DEAL IS,
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $300,000,
I WANT TO BE
THE THIRD PARTNER -- 33 1/3%
I WANT A SAY
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING IN RETAIL,
'CAUSE I CARE ABOUT THAT.
I COULD HELP YOU A LOT
IN SOCIAL-MEDIA PLATFORM
OF THIS SPACE.
YOU KNOW, I-I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN THAT
PREPPER MARKET.
I-I HAVE AN OFFER.
MY OFFER IS $300,000
FOR 20% EQUITY
AND 33 1/3% EQUITY ONLINE.
SO, ANY ONLINE SALES
YOU WANT 1/3 OF?
ALL ONLINE SALES
I WANT 1/3 OF.
YOU'RE ONLY DOING 5% NOW,
AND I THINK I CAN GROW THAT
TO MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THEN, IN STORE,
ALL OTHER THINGS, 20%.
WOW. THANK YOU.
I THINK WE GOT TO
PARTNER TOGETHER ON THIS
AND KNOCK THESE GUYS OUT.
I'LL DO THE ONLINE STUFF.
WE'LL BOTH WORK ON
THE RETAIL.
TOGETHER?
YEAH.
YEAH, I'D DO THAT DEAL.
NO, NOT YOU, KEVIN. LORI.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-HE DOESN'T WANT YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
WHOO!
I'LL TAKE THE --
I'LL TAKE THE WHOLE THING.
-YOU'RE ONE STICK.
-FOR WHAT PERCENTAGE?
SO, FOR WHAT?
WHAT'S THE DEAL?
FOR 30%.
FOR 30%?
YEAH.
'CAUSE I THINK THAT'S FAIR.
FOR 30%?
WHAT IF WE DID 33 1/3%?
HOW'S THAT FAIR?
33 1/3%.
YOU'RE VALUING THEIR COMPANY
AT $1 MILLION.
YEAH, BUT WE'RE GONNA
MAKE IT A LOT BIGGER.
SO, WE'RE 1/3, 1/3, AND 1/3.
O'Leary: I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF THE BUSINESS IS WORTH
MORE THAN A MILLION BUCKS
RIGHT NOW.
SO I DON'T THINK
1/3 IS CRAZY.
WELL, I HAVE A LOT OF PRODUCTS
IN YOUR SPACE.
OH, PERFECT.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW A LOT ABOUT
ALL THE PLACES THAT YOU'RE IN
AND HOW TO REALLY GENERATE
THOSE SALES
AND REALLY BUILD THAT UP
TO BE A LOT BETTER, BROADER,
AND FASTER.
WE -- WE ALL HAVE THAT,
GUYS.
A LITTLE REVISION.
WE ALL HAVE THAT.
EVERYBODY --
IF YOU GUYS WILL DO 20%,
YOU GOT A DEAL.
20% IS NOT ENOUGH.
THAT'S NOT -- IT'S --
NO, IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
I OFFERED YOU 20% EQUITY.
NO?
YEAH, HE DID.
YEAH, I OFFERED YOU
20% EQUITY...
HE OFFERED US 20%.
AND 33% OF THE ONLINE,
WHICH I'LL DO THE ONLINE.
MM-HMM.
Greiner: THERE'S TWO OF US
IN ON THIS.
I'LL HANDLE
ALL OF THE RETAIL END,
AND MARK WILL HANDLE
ALL OF THE ONLINE...
YOU WON'T HAVE TO
TOUCH YOUR WEBSITE.
...AND GROW THAT.
WE WOULD DO 100% OF IT.
I KNOW THE WORK I HAVE TO DO
AND THE WORK I HAVE TO PUT IN,
SO THE OFFER WAS THAT
MARK AND I TOGETHER AT 33.3%.
FOR $300,000.
IT'S A GOOD OFFER.
YOU GUYS KNOW.
KEVIN AND DAYMOND, WHAT
ARE THEY, WOOD CHIPS TO YOU?
YEAH, I MEAN, IF YOU'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN ENTERTAINING THAT,
I MEAN, JUST LET US KNOW.
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
KONEL AND FRANK HAVE
THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE
FROM KEVIN, DAYMOND,
AND MARK AND LORI
FOR THEIR FIRE STARTER COMPANY,
INSTA-FIRE.
KEVIN AND DAYMOND, WHAT ARE
THEY, WOOD CHIPS TO YOU?
John: YEAH, I MEAN,
IF YOU'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN ENTERTAINING THAT,
I MEAN, JUST LET US KNOW.
NO, IT'S A GREAT -- I MEAN,
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE OFFERS.
WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO WEIGH WHICH, YOU KNOW --
THE MARKET THAT YOU NEED IS,
YOU NEED RETAIL.
YOU NEED TO GET THIS OUT THERE.
WE HAVE RETAIL.
WE ALL HAVE RETAIL.
SHE HAS A DEAL THERE.
I HAVE A DEAL AT TRUE VALUE.
BUT YOU'RE IN RETAIL
ALREADY, GUYS.
YEAH. WE ALL --
WE ALL HAVE DEALS.
YOU KNOW THAT.
I LOOK AT IT,
I'M THE KING OF QVC.
SHE'S MY QUEEN.
HE'S THE JOKER OF QVC.
[ LAUGHS ]
HE'S A WANNABE.
HE WANTS TO BE ME.
THE THING IS, WE ALL SELL ON QVC
'CAUSE WE HAVE HUGE BRANDS.
-FRANK, YOU GOT TO --
-THIS IS NOT A QVC PRODUCT.
I'LL GO DOWN TO 17.5% OWNERSHIP,
25% ONLINE.
BUT THAT'S MY FINAL OFFER.
I'LL BLEND IT DOWN TO 25%, JUST
WANT TO DO THE DEAL MYSELF.
25%.
WHAT IF MARK AND I
WENT TO 30%?
-THAT'S STILL A LOT.
-3%?
WELL, THERE'S TWO OF US.
THAT'S THE THING.
THERE'S TWO OF US IN ON THIS,
RIGHT?
YOU NEED TO
GROW YOUR RETAIL.
YOU NEED TO GET INTO
THEIR WAREHOUSES.
YOU NEED TO BE
A CONSTANT FIXTURE.
YOU'RE GONNA GIVE UP
1/3 OF YOUR BUSINESS
TO GET INTO STORES
YOU'RE IN ALREADY?
LOWE'S, MEIJER, ACE,
HOME DEPOT.
OKAY,
I'LL KEEP IT INTERESTING.
I'LL DROP THE EQUITY ASK
ACROSS ALL PLATFORMS TO 20%.
THINK OF IT THIS WAY --
THERE'S A REASON WHY
THEY HAVE TO KEEP ON
DROPPING THEIR EQUITY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
WE CAN ALL SAY THE SAME THING
SHE'S SAYING. WE ALL ADD VALUE.
ALL RIGHT. FRANK,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
MARK AND LORI,
YOU'VE GOT A DEAL.
-YEAH!
-WHOO!
ME TOO. HERE WE GO.
Greiner: DONE.
WE'RE GONNA LIGHT UP THE WORLD.
AH!
THANKS SO MUCH.
MOUNTAIN MAN.
YOU BET.
Cuban:
I DON'T HUG, BUT --
[ LAUGHS ]
WE'LL DO REALLY WELL.
GOOD GOING, BUD.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
-LIGHT THIS ONE.
-WHOO!
WE'LL TAKE IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
PERFECT.
WHOO-HOO!
HEY, GIVE ME A HIGH FIVE!
THAT'S AWESOME!
CHUG, BABY! WHOO!
THAT'S AWESOME, MAN!
WE FEEL UNBELIEVABLE.
CLOUD NINE, BABY.
CLOUD NINE.
WHOO!
Narrator: EARLIER THIS SEASON,
WE WATCHED JORDAN BARROCAS
AND DANIEL FOGELSON MAKE A DEAL
WITH DAYMOND JOHN FOR THEIR
GOURMET BEEF JERKY COMPANY
THREE JERKS JERKY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $100,000
FOR 15%.
AAAAAH!
LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
Barrocas: THINGS HAVE BEEN CRAZY
SINCE "SHARK TANK."
WE HAVE BEEN KNEE-DEEP
IN FILET MIGNON.
THE NIGHT WE AIRED, WE SOLD
A QUARTER OF A MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IN THE 3 MONTHS
SINCE THEN -- $1.4 MILLION.
Fogelson: THAT'S OVER
150,000 BAGS OF JERKY.
Both: AAAAH!
WE'VE BEEN THRILLED
ABOUT OUR SUCCESS,
BUT SUCH INSANE GROWTH
COMES WITH A LOT OF CHALLENGES.
OUR CO-PACKER JUST CAN'T
MEET OUR NEW DEMAND,
AND WE NEED TO EXPAND FAST.
John:
YOU GUYS READY TO DO THIS?
LET'S DO IT.
ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM TO HAVE,
TOO MANY SALES
IS THE ONE YOU WANT.
SO I BROUGHT DANIEL AND JORDAN
TO MEET WITH
RASTELLI FOODS GROUP.
QUALITY AND CONSISTENCY
IS THE ABSOLUTE,
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO US.
I THINK WE CAN HELP.
WE'RE PREPARED TO FILL
THE DEMANDS YOU GUYS HAVE GOT,
BE ABLE TO PROCESS THE PRODUCT,
AND THEN FINALLY,
TO DISTRIBUTE THAT PRODUCT
TO YOUR CUSTOMERS.
WE CAN NOT ONLY
MAINTAIN THE QUALITY,
BUT WE CAN LOWER THE COSTS.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
CAN'T WAIT TO GET GOING.
LET'S TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT STEP.
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO GET THIS
JERKY IN EVERYBODY'S HANDS.
BEING A JERK
HAS NEVER FELT SO GOOD.
CHECK THIS OUT.
Barrocas: DAYMOND SAW
THAT WE WERE STRUGGLING
AND IMMEDIATELY TOOK ACTION.
WITH THIS OFF OF OUR SHOULDERS,
WE CAN FOCUS ON
GROWING OUR BUSINESS AND GETTING
ON MORE AND MORE SHELVES.
THIS WHOLE
"SHARK TANK" EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN THE BEST
FOR OUR BUSINESS.
THE SKY IS THE LIMIT
FOR THREE JERKS JERKY.
AND WE CANNOT WAIT
TO SEE WHAT'S NEXT.
♪♪
MY NAME IS DEE COWGER.
THIS IS MY WIFE, ANGIE.
AND WE LIVE IN THE SMALL TOWN OF
WEBSTER SPRINGS, WEST VIRGINIA.
DEE AND I
WENT TO SCHOOL TOGETHER.
WE WERE IN GRADE SCHOOL,
AND ONE OF MY GIRLFRIENDS
DARED ME TO KISS HIM,
SO I DID.
AND IT MUST HAVE MADE
AN IMPRESSION.
HERE WE ARE, 28 YEARS LATER,
THREE CHILDREN, ONE GRANDCHILD,
TWO MORE ON THE WAY.
HEY, GUYS.
I GOT YOUR HOT DOG.
24 YEARS AGO,
WE OPENED THE CUSTARD STAND,
A FAMILY-OWNED RESTAURANT
SELLING THE BEST HOT DOGS,
ICE CREAM, SANDWICHES,
AND ANYTHING ELSE
YOU CAN THINK OF.
-EVERYTHING GOOD?
-OH, EVERYTHING IS GREAT.
THE MAIN REASON THAT PEOPLE
COME BACK TO THE CUSTARD STAND
IS BECAUSE
IT'S A HOMETOWN FEEL.
NOT TO MENTION
THE FOOD'S GREAT.
[ LAUGHS ]
THERE'S ONE ITEM ON OUR MENU
THAT OUR CUSTOMERS LOVE,
AND THEY DON'T JUST WANT
TO BE ABLE
TO GET IT
AT OUR RESTAURANTS.
SO WE DECIDED TO BRING OUR
PRODUCT TO THE RETAIL MARKET.
WE NEED AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE
A NATIONAL BUSINESS.
WE WANT TO PUT OUR HOMETOWN
AND OUR COMMUNITY ON THE MAP.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S DEE COWGER.
THIS IS MY WIFE,
ANGIE.
AND WE'RE THE PROUD OWNERS
OF CUSTARD STAND FOOD PRODUCTS
IN WEBSTER SPRINGS,
WEST VIRGINIA.
TODAY WE'RE HERE SEEKING
$400,000 FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
-OOH!
-WOW.
24 YEARS AGO,
WE OPENED A SMALL DAIRY BAR
IN WEBSTER SPRINGS,
WEST VIRGINIA,
SELLING ICE CREAM, HOT DOGS,
SANDWICHES, AND SIDES.
OUR NUMBER-ONE-SELLING ITEM
FOR 24 STRAIGHT YEARS
IS OUR HOT DOGS
WITH CHILI.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THE RICH AND MEATY CHILI
THAT WE TOP THOSE HOT DOGS WITH
IS A RECIPE FROM MY GRANDPA.
IT'S BEEN IN OUR FAMILY,
PASSED DOWN
FROM GENERATION TO GENERATION
SINCE THE 1920s.
AFTER COUNTLESS
CUSTOMER REQUESTS,
WE BROUGHT
OUR FAMOUS HOT DOG CHILI
TO THE RETAIL MARKET.
CUSTARD STAND
HOT DOG CHILI
IS AN ALL-BEEF HOT DOG CHILI
WITH NO FILLERS.
THERE'S NO SOY,
NO TEXTURED VEGETABLE PROTEIN,
CRACKERS, OATS --
NONE OF THAT KIND OF STUFF.
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL ADDITIVES,
PRESERVATIVES, GLUTEN,
OR TRANS FAT
IN OUR PRODUCT.
YOU CAN PRONOUNCE EVERY SINGLE
INGREDIENT ON THAT LABEL.
AND DID I SAY THAT BEEF
IS THE NUMBER-ONE INGREDIENT
ON THAT LABEL?
SO, SHARKS, IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO TRY OUR FAMOUS HOT DOG CHILI.
MMM.
WHAT ARE WE WAITING FOR?
WHAT? BRING IT ON.
[ LAUGHS ]
OUR HOT DOG CHILI
DOES NOT HAVE BEANS.
OUR CHILI SOUP DOES HAVE BEANS
AND DICED TOMATOES
AND JUST A LITTLE BIT
MORE HEAT.
SO...
BRING ON THE HEAT!
-IT'S PRETTY SWEET.
-VERY GOOD.
IT IS A LITTLE SWEET.
GOT IT.
YEAH, IT'S GOOD.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: AND YOU MUST HAVE
A LOT OF SALES,
'CAUSE YOU'RE ASKING
FOR $400,000 FOR 10%.
$1.6 MILLION.
LAST YEAR.
-WOW.
-WHOA. GOOD FOR YOU.
-THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
SO, DEE, TELL US HOW
YOU'RE SELLING IT.
UH, WE'RE IN WALMART,
WE'RE IN KROGER.
KROGER'S, SAM'S CLUB...
BUT JUST
ON A REGIONAL BASIS.
JUST ON A REGIONAL BASIS.
IS THAT BECAUSE THE TASTE,
THEY FEEL, IS REGIONAL?
HOT DOG CHILI
IS A REGIONAL PRODUCT.
SO, ANGIE, YOU HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL RESTAURANT,
YOU HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL CHILI BUSINESS,
WHY DO YOU NEED $400,000?
WHAT'S THE BIG PLAN?
WE WANT TO BE
THAT NATIONAL BRAND.
WE WANT TO BE THAT PRODUCT
THAT IS EVERYWHERE.
ON THE $1.5 MILLION...
OKAY.
...WHAT DID YOU MAKE
AS A PROFIT?
$217,000.
IS THAT AFTER
YOU PAID YOURSELF SOMETHING?
YES.
AND, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE ONE RESTAURANT
THAT BELONGS TO US,
AND THEN WE HAVE
FIVE FRANCHISE LOCATIONS.
IS THAT PART OF THE $1.6 MILLION
COMING IN?
NO.
WHAT'S YOUR REVENUE
PER FRANCHISE?
THEY'RE DOING
PROBABLY AROUND $20,000.
YOU'RE NOT PUTTING THOSE
AS PART AS THE DEAL?
WE DID NOT ANTICIPATE PUTTING
THOSE AS PART OF THE DEAL.
IN REGARDS TO THIS BUSINESS,
I LIKE IT, I ATE IT --
REALLY GOOD.
BUT MORE CONCERNING TO ME
IS THE 400K.
TO ROLL OUT NATIONWIDE,
YOU NEED R&D TO KEEP
THE INTEGRITY OF THE PRODUCT.
THEN YOU HAVE TO DO YOUR
IN-STORE ROLL-OUTS NATIONWIDE.
AND THEN
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
SOME FORM OF
BUSINESS-TO-CONSUMER ADVERTISING
TO TELL THEM
YOU'RE AT THE STORE.
I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF 400K IS GOING TO DO THAT.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THE WORDS.
WE DO HAVE A PLAN
THAT INCLUDES, YOU KNOW,
THE PROFIT FROM THIS YEAR
THAT WE ESTIMATE
TO BE ABOUT $400,000.
IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE GENERATING A LOT OF CASH.
IS THERE ANY DEBT
ON THE BUSINESS TODAY?
THERE IS.
YES, THERE IS DEBT.
THERE'S ABOUT $700,000
WORTH OF DEBT ON THE BUSINESS.
[ ALL GROAN ]
-I DIDN'T EVEN GET TO THAT!
-$700,000?
-SO, YOU GOT TO --
-WE GOT A FLY IN THE CHILI.
$320,000 OF THAT DEBT...
OH, MY GOD.
...IS FROM
THE BRICK-AND-MORTAR STORE
THAT CUSTARD STAND
FOOD PRODUCTS OWNS.
AND THE OTHER $400,000?
WE HAVE
A BRAND-NEW FREEZER.
18x36.
WE CAN STACK
THREE PALLETS HIGH,
AND WE DRIVE FORKLIFTS
IN AND OUT OF IT.
THAT'S A LOT OF DEBT
FOR THE SIZE YOU ARE.
NEITHER OF US HAVE A BUSINESS
OR A MARKETING BACKGROUND.
WE'RE THE AMERICAN DREAM.
WE'RE RAISING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF ENTREPRENEURS.
-YES, YOU ARE.
-ABSOLUTELY.
Greiner: LOOK WHAT YOU'VE DONE.
ALL THREE OF OUR CHILDREN --
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GOOD AT.
YOU'RE DOING OKAY.
I MEAN, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
WHAT YOU'VE DONE, THOUGH --
YOU'RE GRINDING IT OUT
AND DOING A GREAT JOB.
YEAH, WE ARE. WE HAVE.
WE REALLY HAVE.
YOU ARE CRUSHING IT.
I MEAN, THINK ABOUT IT --
YOU START WITH THE STAND,
YOU'RE GETTING IT
INTO MAJOR FOOD CHAINS,
SO YOU'RE REALLY DOING
A GREAT JOB.
WHILE I THINK IT'S GREAT
IN YOUR REGION,
FOR ME,
I'M NOT PASSIONATE ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I LIKE
A SPICY CHILI.
I'M OUT.
WELL, IF YOU DECIDE
TO RECONSIDER,
WE'VE GOT ENOUGH PASSION
FOR ALL OF US.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ANGIE, I THINK YOU GUYS
ARE KILLING IT.
I MEAN, YOU STARTED A BUSINESS
WITH ONE STAND.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
THANKS.
SO I DON'T HAVE
ANY ISSUE WITH THAT.
AND I THINK
YOU GUYS LOVE THE PRODUCT.
RIGHT.
WHICH I WOULD --
WE STILL EAT HOT DOGS
AT HOME REGULARLY.
YEAH,
WE EAT THEM REGULAR.
THAT'S WHAT I LOOK FOR.
YOU'RE PASSIONATE ABOUT IT.
I LOVE ALL THAT.
BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY CHALLENGING
TO TAKE
A CHILI SAUCE LIKE THIS
AND ROLL IT OUT
ON A NATIONAL BASIS
WHEN THERE'S
A LOT OF REGIONAL TASTE.
I DON'T SEE HOW YOU'RE GONNA GO
FROM REGIONAL TO NATIONAL
IN A FOOD PRODUCT
LIKE THIS.
I'M OUT.
I LOOK AT IT THIS WAY --
WE'VE HAD A JOURNEY HERE
IN THE TANK TODAY,
AND I'M A NUMBERS GUY,
SO LET ME JUST LAY OUT
WHAT I THINK THIS LOOKS LIKE.
YOU'RE ASKING ME
FOR $400,000 FOR 10%.
A BIG PLAYER
THAT WAS IN THIS MARKET
THAT ALREADY SOLD, YOU KNOW,
CHILI SOMEWHERE ELSE
AND WANTED TO CONSOLIDATE
THIS BRAND
WOULD PAY ABOUT
A MILLION DOLLARS FOR IT.
YOU WANT TO VALUE IT
AT $4 MILLION.
THAT'S A VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE.
YOU WANT ME TO SAY
THAT THE BRAND MAKES UP
THE OTHER $3 MILLION
WORTH OF VALUE.
THAT'S A LOT FOR THIS BRAND
THAT'S REGIONAL. IT REALLY IS.
THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Cuban:
HERE'S WHAT I SEE.
YOU COME IN
ASKING FOR $400,000 FOR 10%.
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE A BUSINESS
VALUED AT $4 MILLION.
THAT MAKES YOU GUYS
MULTI-MILLIONAIRES.
THAT'S WHY I DO THE SHOW --
'CAUSE EVERYBODY IN AMERICA
IS WATCHING THIS SHOW WONDERING,
CAN THEY BE THAT COUPLE?
CAN THEY BE THAT COUPLE
THAT COMES FROM SOME TOWN
NO ONE'S EVER HEARD OF
TO START A STAND
AND BUILD A BUSINESS
WHERE YOU'RE MAKING
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR?
THANK YOU.
NOW, FROM
AN INVESTOR'S PERSPECTIVE,
THERE'S
TOO MANY MOVING PARTS.
WONDERING WHERE
YOUR TIME WAS BEING SPENT
RELATIVE TO MY INVESTMENT
WOULD BE A NIGHTMARE.
FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT,
BUT I'M HERE TO TELL YOU --
YOU ARE EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYBODY WATCHING THIS SHOW
ASPIRES TO BE, SO YOU SHOULD BE
VERY PROUD OF YOURSELF.
THANK YOU.
-GOOD LUCK.
-GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
-GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
♪♪
THE DISAPPOINTMENT'S
DEFINITELY THERE.
WE WORKED REALLY HARD
TO GET HERE.
BUT WE'LL OVERCOME IT.
YOU KNOW...
WE'RE STRONG TOGETHER.
...WE'RE STRONG TOGETHER.
WE DRAW STRENGTH
FROM EACH OTHER
AND FROM OUR FAMILY
AND OUR FRIENDS.
AND, YOU KNOW, THAT STRENGTH
IS WHAT WILL MAKE US,
YOU KNOW,
BIGGER AND BETTER.
♪♪
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A HOME GYM
THAT FITS INTO
EVEN THE SMALLEST SPACES.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS
ERIK HOPPERSTAD.
AND I'M BRIAN BRASCH.
WE'RE FROM FARGO,
NORTH DAKOTA,
AND OUR COMPANY IS
PRX PERFORMANCE.
WE ARE SEEKING
$80,000
FOR A 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
"I CAN'T BELIEVE SOMEBODY
DIDN'T THINK OF THIS SOONER!"
"THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR."
"GENIUS!"
"WOW!"
SHARKS, THESE ARE JUST
A FEW OF THE THINGS PEOPLE SAY
WHEN THEY FIRST SEE
OUR PRX PERFORMANCE PRODUCTS.
WE HAVE REDESIGNED TRADITIONAL
WEIGHT-TRAINING EQUIPMENT,
SO WHEN IT'S NOT IN USE,
IT TAKES UP JUST INCHES
OF YOUR VALUABLE SPACE.
OUR FLAGSHIP PRODUCT,
THE PROFILE RACK,
IS A SLIM RIG THAT
EASILY TRANSFORMS ANY SPACE
INTO A MULTI-FUNCTIONING GYM.
YOU CAN SQUAT.
YOU CAN BENCH-PRESS.
YOU CAN DO PULL-UPS.
BUT WHEN NOT IN USE,
IT FOLDS AWAY,
TAKING UP JUST A FEW INCHES
ON YOUR WALL.
OUR DESIGNS NOW ALLOW
FOR REAL GYM EQUIPMENT
TO BE USED IN SPACES
THAT HAVE NEVER BEEN POSSIBLE --
YOUR GARAGE, YOUR BASEMENT,
YOUR SMALL COMMERCIAL SPACE.
ANYPLACE
CAN NOW BE A REAL GYM.
"INCREDIBLE!"
"AMAZING!"
"BEST INVESTMENT
I EVER MADE!"
SHARKS, THESE ARE
JUST A FEW THINGS
YOU MIGHT BE SAYING
AFTER TODAY.
SO, WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
WANT TO HELP US
SHAKE UP THE FITNESS SPACE
BY TAKING UP
AS LITTLE SPACE AS POSSIBLE?
Herjavec: TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW IT WORKS.
HOW DOES IT LOCK INTO PLACE?
'CAUSE YOU HAVE
AN ENTIRE STRUCTURE BEHIND YOU.
YEP, SO,
IT'S MADE TO BE ATTACHED
ON 16 INCH ON CENTER
OR 2 FOOT ON CENTER STUDS.
BUT DO I NEED
ALL OF THAT BEHIND IT?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
Greiner:
NO, YOU JUST NEED A WALL.
YOU JUST NEED A WALL.
A VERY STABLE WALL.
A STRUCTURAL --
A STRONG WALL.
MOST OF THE WEIGHT IS ON
THE TWO ACTUAL POSTS, RIGHT?
EXACTLY.
RIGHT.
SO,
HE'LL PULL IT DOWN
AND PUT IT IN
THE USABLE POSITION AGAIN.
Herjavec:
YEAH. HOW DO I ADJUST IT?
CAN I MAKE IT GO UP AND DOWN,
THE TOP BAR?
ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN YOU INSTALL IT,
YOU CAN PUT THAT
WHEREVER
YOU'D LIKE IT TO BE.
DOES IT COME
WITH THE WEIGHTS?
OR DO YOU HAVE TO HAVE
YOUR OWN SET?
WE SELL JUST THE RACK
AS YOU SEE IT MOUNTED
TO THE WALL SEPARATELY.
AND WE ALSO HAVE
ABOUT 30 OTHER PRODUCTS
THAT WE'VE DESIGNED
THAT COMPLEMENT THIS WELL.
HOW MUCH IS IT?
THIS RIG RIGHT HERE,
OUR COMMERCIAL LINE,
IS $1,099 RETAIL.
IS THERE A CONSUMER LINE?
John: THAT'S A LOT.
THERE IS. WE'RE JUST
LAUNCHING NOW A STANDARD LINE.
HOW MUCH WOULD
A CONSUMER ONE BE?
THEY START AT $550.
WHO ASSEMBLES IT?
AND WHO PUTS IT UP ON THE WALL?
ASSEMBLY IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE END USER.
HOW EASY
IS THE INSTALLATION?
CAN YOU DO IT 5 MINUTES?
IS IT 30 MINUTES?
NO. ONE TO TWO HOURS
IS WHAT WE SAY.
-OKAY.
-HOW'D YOU COME UP WITH THIS?
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE FITNESS INDUSTRY NOW
FOR THREE AND FOUR YEARS,
AND AS WE GOT INTO IT,
WE JUST SAW OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAD A LARGE COMPETITOR
IN THAT SPACE.
THEY WERE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO BUY EQUIPMENT
AND FILL UP
THEIR ENTIRE GARAGE STALL
AND WORK OUT
IN THEIR GYM.
AND, BEING FROM
FARGO, NORTH DAKOTA --
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO
VISIT THERE IN FEBRUARY.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE CAN'T GIVE UP
OUR GARAGE STALL.
WE GOT TO FIGURE --
I MEAN, I SAID,
"WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THIS."
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT ON THIS?
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
IT IS PATENT PENDING.
WE WERE THE PIONEERS.
WE WERE THE VERY FIRST
TO LAUNCH THIS THING.
THERE'S TWO
PRETTY BIG COMPANIES
THAT HAVE SINCE
RELEASED SOMETHING.
THEY ARE IN VIOLATION
OF OUR CLAIMS
IF OUR PATENT'S ACCEPTED
THE WAY IT IS.
YOU'RE ASSUMING
YOU HAVE A PATENT COMING.
THEY'RE VIOLATING IT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT,
'CAUSE KEVIN'S GONNA
MAKE YOU AN OFFER
IF YOU'RE GONNA SUE THEM
INTO THE STONE AGE.
[ LAUGHS ]
HAVE YOU GONE TO
THE PATENT TRADEMARK OFFICE
AND SAID THERE'S AN INFRINGEMENT
TO TRY AND FAST-TRACK IT?
Cuban: OKAY, WELL, INSTEAD OF
TALKING ABOUT BEING LITIGIOUS,
LET'S TALK ABOUT
YOUR BUSINESS.
WHAT?
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN SELLING?
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU BEEN SELLING?
WE STARTED SELLING THIS PRODUCT
Q3 OF LAST YEAR.
THIS YEAR, SO FAR, WE'VE DONE
A LITTLE OVER $170,000.
AND HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD
SINCE Q3?
WE JUST CROSSED
100 UNITS.
AND DID YOU MAKE MONEY?
WE MADE MONEY
THIS QUARTER,
HOWEVER, WE HAVE NOT
TAKEN SALARIES YET.
WHAT'S YOUR GROSS MARGIN
ON THESE NEW UNITS?
RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE AT A 43%.
WE WILL ACTUALLY
GET IT UP TO 50%.
Cuban: YEAH, YOU HAVE TO,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SO MUCH CAPITAL OUTLAY
FOR INVENTORY.
YOU HAVE TO TURN A LOT.
AND, GUYS, THAT'S REALLY
MY PROBLEM, RIGHT?
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS GOOD
FOR TWO GUYS OWNING A BUSINESS
TRYING TO MAKE SOME MONEY.
BUT TO COME IN
AND BRING IN AN INVESTOR,
THAT CHANGES EVERYTHING,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE THEN YOU HAVE TO START
WORRYING ABOUT OUR RETURN
OR REINVESTING
IN THE COMPANY,
AND YOU'RE
WAY, WAY, WAY TOO EARLY.
YOU GUYS ARE TWO GUYS
THAT HAVE A GOOD PRODUCT,
BUT I JUST THINK
IT'S NOT QUITE RIGHT FOR ME.
SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
AND WE ACTUALLY,
IN ADDITION TO THE $80,000,
WE WOULD BE LOOKING FOR
A LINE OF CREDIT, AS WELL.
GUYS, I LOVE
THE FITNESS INDUSTRY.
I'VE DONE A BUNCH
OF INVESTMENTS HERE.
HERE'S WHAT I'VE LEARNED.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY IN THE FITNESS BUSINESS,
YOU WANT A PRODUCT THAT APPEALS
TO A VERY WIDE GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT'S EASY TO USE.
THE CHALLENGE WITH THIS IS, IT'S
GONNA SCARE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IT'S TECHNICAL, IT LOOKS
COMPLICATED, IT LOOKS HARD.
THE IDEA OF ME ASSEMBLING THIS
IS NEVER GONNA WORK.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO FIND A STUD IN A WALL.
I THINK IT'S NOT GONNA APPEAL
TO A WIDE-ENOUGH BASE OF PEOPLE
WHERE I CAN INVEST
AND SEE IT SCALE.
I'M OUT.
I KNOW HOW TO FIND
A STUD IN A WALL.
ALL RIGHT!
[ LAUGHS ]
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
WELL, SO THAT'S...
ALL KIDDING ASIDE,
I THINK IT'S BRILLIANT.
WE HAVE ALSO HAVE
LICENSING INTERESTS.
IT'S A GREAT SPACE-SAVER.
I DON'T THINK
IT LOOKS DIFFICULT TO INSTALL.
BUT I HOPE YOU GET YOUR PATENT,
AND THEN YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO REALLY MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS SPACE.
RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE EARLY FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
THANKS, LORI.
THANK YOU, LORI.
APPRECIATE IT.
John: I HAPPEN TO KNOW
THIS SPACE FAIRLY WELL.
THERE ARE TWO TYPE OF USERS.
THIS USER
WHO'S THE ENTHUSIAST,
99% OF THEM
PUT IT UNDERNEATH THEIR BED,
AND THEY NEED TO BUY A DUSTER
WITH THE EQUIPMENT
BECAUSE THEY NEVER USE IT.
OR YOU HAVE THE ENTHUSIAST
WHO GOES AND PAYS $300 A MONTH
TO BE A MEMBER.
I SEE THIS
AS BEING THAT AREA
WHERE IT'S VERY, VERY HARD
TO GRAB ONE OR THE OTHER.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
AND THEN THERE WAS ONLY KEVIN,
THE FITTEST SHARK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
UM, I-I LIKE IT.
I'M SORT OF CONNECTING WITH IT,
'CAUSE MY WIFE'S PUTTING A GYM
INTO OUR BASEMENT RIGHT NOW
AT OUR LAKE HOUSE,
AND SHE'S RUN INTO
THIS PROBLEM.
AND I THINK IT'S
A VERY INTERESTING SOLUTION.
HOW WOULD YOU PAY BACK
AN INVESTOR
THAT GAVE YOU $80,000?
YOU PUT AN $800,000 VALUE
ON THIS.
I HAVE NO IDEA
IF IT'S WORTH THAT OR NOT.
BASED ON OUR PROJECTIONS,
WE'LL SELL
ANOTHER 300 UNITS THIS YEAR.
THAT'S THE WAY
WE'RE TRENDING RIGHT NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE AVERAGE
SELLING PRICE WILL BE
ON THOSE 300 UNITS?
PROBABLY AROUND $700.
I'D LOOK AT IT THIS WAY --
I'D GIVE YOU THE $80,000
FOR 20%.
AND THE WAY I WOULD STRUCTURE
THE PAYBACK WOULD BE,
AS YOU PAY YOURSELVES 80%,
I GET 20%.
YOU NEED THE CAPITAL
FOR THE FIRST 100 UNITS.
I THINK
IT'S AN ELOQUENT SOLUTION.
AND I'M ASSUMING
THE PATENT'S GONNA HOLD UP.
BY THE WAY, I'LL SHOW YOU
HOW TO SUE THOSE GUYS
INTO THE STONE AGE.
[ LAUGHS ]
WAITING FOR THAT.
YEP.
WONDERFUL.
THAT'S AWESOME.
GUYS, NO ONE ELSE
HAS MADE YOU AN OFFER.
I'M THE ONLY ONE
THAT BELIEVES IN YOU.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
LET'S DO IT.
YOU GOT A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO WORK.
Cuban: CONGRATS, GUYS.
Greiner: CONGRATS, GUYS.
-THANKS A LOT, GUYS.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
-ALL RIGHT. GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
-LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
HEY, GUYS,
WHILE YOU'RE UP THERE,
CAN WE SEE KEVIN
DO A CHIN-UP?
ROBERT, I DON'T WANT
TO EMBARRASS YOU.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU, GUYS,
VERY MUCH.
YEAH! WHOO!
[ LAUGHS ]
THOSE ARE GREAT GUYS --
JUST REALLY BAD
JUDGE OF CHARACTER.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
KEVIN COME BACK RIPPED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A MOM
WHO TURNED HER HOMEMADE
KIDS CLOTHES INTO A BRAND.
♪♪
HI. MY NAME'S RACHEL NILSSON,
AND I AM FROM ALPINE, UTAH.
I AM SEEKING $200,000
FOR 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN MY COMPANY
CALLED RAGS TO RACHES.
WHAT STARTED AS A SIDE BUSINESS
SELLING MY KIDS'
HAND-ME-DOWN CLOTHING
TO HELP MAKE ENDS MEET
ENDED UP
BECOMING A FASHION FRENZY.
WE CALL THIS THE ROMPER.
IT'S A ONE-PIECE OUTFIT
THAT'S SUPER-EASY
TO SLIDE ON AND OFF
YOUR WRIGGLY TODDLER
WITHOUT THE HASSLE
OF DEALING WITH SNAPS.
I STARTED POSTING THESE
ON MY SOCIAL MEDIA,
AND THE RESPONSE WAS CRAZINESS.
PARENTS LOVED THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE SUPER-COMFORTABLE
AND STYLISH,
BUT THEY'RE ALSO VERY PRACTICAL.
SINCE LAUNCH,
THESE HAVE BEEN IN HIGH DEMAND.
IT'S BECAUSE OF OUR LIMITED RUNS
AND OUR SUPER-EXCLUSIVE DESIGNS.
NOW I'D LIKE TO SHOW YOU GUYS
THE ROMPER IN ACTION.
CHLOE! HARRISON!
[ LAUGHTER ]
AWW!
SHARK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
-COME ON!
-OH, MY GOD, THAT'S CUTE.
-OH, MY GOD.
-HI!
SAY "HI."
WHO'S WHO?
OKAY, THIS IS
MY LITTLE GUY HARRISON.
HI, HARRISON.
AND THIS IS CHLOE.
HI, CHLOE.
Greiner: HI, CHLOE.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THEY'RE BOTH WEARING
TWO DIFFERENT STYLES OF ROMPERS,
BOTH EQUALLY JUST AS STYLISH.
AND WE'RE NOT HAVING TO
NEGOTIATE AT ALL ON COMFORT.
SHARKS, I WANT TO GET THESE
IN THE HANDS OF EVERY
STYLISH PARENT OUT THERE.
NOW THEY'RE GONNA HELP US
HAND OUT SOME SAMPLES.
CAN YOU HAND HIM
THE TOP ONE?
VERY GOOD.
OH, THANK YOU.
OKAY,
AND NOW OUR FRIEND LORI.
THANK YOU, HONEY.
OH, WATCH YOUR STEP.
DO YOU WANT TO GET UP
ON THE STAIR?
CHLOE, DON'T GET TOO CLOSE
TO MR. O'LEARY.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU.
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY. AND NOW
OUR FRIEND DAYMOND.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN MARK.
WHAT'S UP, CHLOE?
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU SAY "GOODBYE"?
CAN YOU SAY "BYE"?
Chloe: BYE-BYE!
All: BYE-BYE!
O'Leary: SO, RACHEL,
I HAVE A BURNING QUESTION.
YES, PLEASE.
HOW WOULD A CHILD HAVE
A "PEE-PEE" IN ONE OF THESE?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE GET ASKED THIS QUESTION
ALL OF THE TIME.
THEY LITERALLY SLIDE DOWN
AND UP, AND IT'S NO HASSLE.
PARENTS LOVE THE FACT THEY'RE
SUPER-EASY TO PULL ON AND OFF.
SO, THIS STRETCHES
ALL THE WAY DOWN?
ABSOLUTELY. YEAH.
THE NECKLINE IS REINFORCED
WITH ELASTIC.
SO THE CHILD
PULLS IT --
SO, RACHEL,
THAT'S THE UNIQUE PART.
TOTALLY. YEAH.
WHAT AGE DOES THIS GO TO?
USUALLY, THE BIGGEST SELLERS
ARE INFANT/TODDLER AREA.
RIGHT.
BUT WE HAVE HAD, LIKE,
A 5- AND 6-YEAR-OLD CHILD
WEARING THOSE.
AND HOW MANY
COLORS AND STYLES?
THAT'S THE UNIQUE THING
ABOUT OUR BRAND,
IS WE'RE CONSTANTLY COMING OUT
WITH LIMITED-EDITION.
SO WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DRIVE PEOPLE TO OUR WEBSITE
ALL OF THE TIME.
RACHEL,
WHAT HAVE YOU SOLD?
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE OVER A YEAR,
AND OUR SALES ARE $792,000.
-WHOA.
-GOOD FOR YOU.
FROM -- FROM ZERO?
Nilsson: FROM ZERO.
FROM A COLD START?
-ALL ONLINE?
-YES.
I STARTED THIS BECAUSE
MY HUSBAND WAS IN GRAD SCHOOL.
WE WERE BROKE AS A JOKE,
AND I DECIDED, YOU KNOW WHAT?
LIKE, "I NEED
TO DO SOMETHING HERE."
I HAVE THREE SONS.
I PULLED OUT
THEIR HAND-ME-DOWN CLOTHING,
I CAME UP WITH AN INSTAGRAM
NAME, "RAGS TO RACHES,"
AND I STARTED SELLING
MY KIDS HAND-ME-DOWN CLOTHING.
I WAS NOTICING THAT THE QUICKEST
THINGS THAT WERE SELLING
WERE THE STUFF
THAT I MADE FOR THEM.
SO I CUT A ROMPER
OUT OF MY HUSBAND'S T-SHIRT,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"THIS IS AWESOME."
SO, OUT OF THE $792,000,
IS IT ALL ROMPERS?
NO.
MAJORITY IS, THOUGH.
I WOULD PROBABLY SAY
95% IS ROMPERS.
ARE ALL YOUR SALES
ONLINE?
ACTUALLY, 12% OF OUR SALES
ARE WHOLESALE.
BUT 88% ARE ONLINE.
YES. YEAH.
THOSE 12% ARE GOING
TO RETAILER STORES?
SO, I'VE STUCK WITH, LIKE,
LITTLE BOUTIQUES
BECAUSE I'M SO AFRAID
OF WHOLESALE.
YOU SHOULD BE.
GOOD FOR YOU.
TOTALLY. I DON'T WANT TO BE
HANDCUFFED BY MY RETAILERS.
I LOVE THE ONLINE BUSINESS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THE MONEY'S AT.
Cuban: WELL, YEAH, OKAY.
THAT'S AWESOME.
SO, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
KILLING IT, RACHEL.
IF YOU DID 700-SOME-THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SALES,
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE MADE
A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR.
YEAH, WE'RE PREDICTED
TO DO ALMOST A MILLION.
LIKE, WE'LL PROBABLY --
NO, NO.
I'M TALKING ABOUT PROFIT.
WHAT'S YOUR PROFIT?
PROFIT -- PROFIT, WE'RE DOING --
IT'S LIKE $280,000.
WHY AREN'T YOU
MAKING MORE?
OUR COSTS. LIKE, WE NEED TO GET
OUR COSTS IN THIS --
WHAT ARE YOUR MARGINS?
SO, THE COST TO GET THOSE MADE
IS BETWEEN $7 AND $10.
WE'RE SELLING THEM
FOR 37 TO 50 BUCKS.
WHY ISN'T YOUR PROFIT
WAY HIGHER?
WHERE'S THE REST
OF THE MONEY GOING?
SO, WE ARE, LIKE --
OBVIOUSLY, THAT'S KIND OF WHY
I NEED YOUR GUYS' HELP.
A LOT OF MY PROFITS
IS SUCKED UP INTO MATERIAL.
IT'S YOUR INVENTORY,
YEAH.
YEAH, MY INVENTORY.
O'Leary:
RACHEL, ARE YOU WORRIED,
WHEN SOMEBODY SEES THIS,
THEY COULD SIMPLY KNOCK IT OFF
AT A MUCH LOWER PRICE?
YEAH. I AM SO GLAD YOU ASKED
THAT, BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY --
SO AM I, ACTUALLY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE'VE RUN INTO --
WE'VE RUN INTO PEOPLE
TRYING TO KNOCK OFF RAGS.
WHAT STOPS THEM?
AND WHAT HAPPENED?
THE COOLEST PART IS
I HONESTLY FEEL LIKE
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A BRAND.
PEOPLE LOVE RAGS.
THEY LOVE THE UNIQUENESS OF IT.
I FEEL LIKE I POUR A LITTLE BIT
OF ME INTO THE BRAND,
AND THEY BECOME A FAN
OF NOT ONLY MY BRAND, BUT ME.
I PUT A FACE ON IT,
AND THEY LOVE THAT.
WELL, LET'S TAP INTO OUR
RESIDENT CLOTHING EXPERT HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THAT STATEMENT, DAYMOND --
THAT IT'S PROTECTABLE
BY BRAND ALONE?
THAT IT'LL PROTECT HER.
NO. NOT AT ALL.
I THINK THAT SHE HAS
A GREAT FOLLOWING,
BUT IF ANOTHER MAKER --
AND THEY WILL COPY IT --
PUTS IT OUT THERE...
THIS IS A BIG WORLD,
YOU KNOW?
YEAH, TOTALLY.
THEY JUST WOULDN'T --
YOU KNOW, THEY JUST WOULDN'T --
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
AND WHAT WOULD THEY
SELL IT FOR? SHE'S AT 50 BUCKS.
WHAT WOULD THEY SELL IT?
IT ALL DEPENDS ON THE CHAIN.
SO, IF THIS WAS GOING INTO
THE MASS MARKET,
IT WOULD PROBABLY BE
$19.99.
AT THE MOST.
YEAH, AT THE MOST.
SO, RACHEL, YOU'RE ASKING
FOR $200,000.
Nilsson: YEAH.
YOU MADE $280,000
IN PROFITS.
YEAH.
HOW MUCH OF THAT
DO YOU STILL HAVE LEFT?
I HAVE ALMOST ALL OF THAT.
SO YOU'RE ASKING FOR LESS
THAN YOU HAVE IN CASH ALREADY.
I HAVE TWO --
I THINK I HAVE $215,000
SITTING IN MY BANK ACCOUNT
RIGHT NOW.
SO, WHAT IS THE CASH
GONNA DO FOR YOU TO MAR--
YOU'VE ALREADY GOT
$215,000.
I NEED MORE INVENTORY.
OKAY, BUT HANG ON.
DO YOU WANT MORE INVENTORY
TO GO TO WHOLESALE?
IS THAT WHAT --
NO. THIS IS MY POINT.
ALL THE RETAILERS THAT WE HAVE
APPROVED TO PUT IN THEIR STORES,
THEY ALL SOLD OUT
OF THEIR PRODUCT,
AND THEY'RE COMING TO US,
AND WE HAVE TO SAY, "NO.
WE CAN'T GIVE THAT TO YOU.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH."
SO THIS IS JUST
THE RETAILER SIDE
THAT YOU WANT TO
CREATE THAT FOR.
YEAH, YOU KNOW --
BUT ARE YOU SURE -- ARE YOU SURE
YOU WANT TO GO INTO RETAILERS?
I'M NOT SURE.
SO, RACHEL,
WHAT'S THE DIRECTION?
LIKE, I HEAR YOU TALKING ABOUT
"I'M AN EXCLUSIVE BRAND,"
THEN I HEAR YOU TALKING ABOUT
MORE CASH FOR RETAIL.
I'M SO GLAD
YOU MENTIONED THAT, SO...
LIKE, WHAT --
WHAT'S THE STRATEGY?
I REALLY WOULDN'T MIND
BRANCHING OUT.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
I GO INTO --
AND THAT MEANS
GOING INTO RETAIL?
IF I GO INTO RETAIL,
I DON'T WANT TO BE COMPETING
WITH MYSELF ONLINE.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS WE'VE CREATED
A TOTALLY EXCLUSIVE LINE
FOR OUR RETAILERS.
I WONDER
IF THAT'S GONNA WORK,
BECAUSE THE DIFFERENCE
IN MARGINS TO YOU IS MATERIAL.
THE RETAIL SALE
IS HALF THE PROFIT
THAT YOU'RE MAKING
SELLING DIRECT.
YEAH.
I'M JUST WONDERING WHY.
I MEAN, IT'S WORKING
SO WELL FOR YOU.
YEAH, WHY NOT KEEP
DRIVING IT ONLINE?
WHY NOT KEEP ENGAGING?
LIKE, MAYBE WE WILL,
YOU KNOW?
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE --
RACHEL,
HERE'S WHAT I SEE.
I AGREE WITH THESE GUYS
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
YOU'RE KILLING IT.
YOU MAY BE --
KILLING IT.
YOU MAY BE
THE MOST PROFITABLE
FROM A SALES-TO-NET-PROFIT
COMPANY
THAT WE'VE HAD ON HERE
IN A LONG TIME.
WOW.
WHY SCREW IT UP?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S LIKE...
I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU, MARK,
AND I AM --
BUT YOU DIDN'T, THOUGH,
RIGHT?
BECAUSE ON ONE HAND,
"TOTALLY. AWESOME. IT'S GREAT.
I AGREE WITH YOU, MARK."
BUT THEN,
ON THE OTHER HAND,
IT'S, "OH, YEAH,
RETAIL STORES," RIGHT?
"TOTALLY. AWESOME."
HERE'S THE DEAL.
"WE WANT TO DO IT."
I WOULD GO NUTS.
HERE'S THE DEAL, MARK.
I AM NOT SURE
IF I WANT TO GO THAT ROUTE.
YOU'RE TRYING TO PLAY
A WHOLE NOTHER GAME,
AND YOU DON'T KNOW
IF YOU SHOULD PLAY.
YOU'VE SEEN
OTHER PEOPLE PLAY,
"SO MAYBE I SHOULD PLAY BECAUSE
OTHER COMPANIES ARE BIGGER."
YOU ARE GREAT
AT DESIGNING...
YEAH.
...GETTING PEOPLE
TO TRUST YOU,
AND SELLING THEM
A GREAT PRODUCT ONLINE
AT HUGE MARGINS
THAT'S PROFITABLE TO YOU.
I LOVE IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT THEN,
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
WHEN SOMEONE ELSE
TALKS TO YOU, RIGHT...
"WHOLESALE!"
"'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW."
HERE'S THE DEAL --
"HERE'S THE DEAL,
RIGHT?"
RACHEL, YOU'VE EXCEEDED
MY "HERE'S THE DEAL" QUOTA.
YOU CAN'T MAKE UP YOUR MIND
ABOUT MAKING UP YOUR MIND.
SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANKS, MARK.
THANK YOU.
RACHEL, YOUR PRODUCT
IS NOT DEFENSIBLE.
YEAH.
YOUR BRAND IS.
ABSOLUTELY.
MY CHALLENGE IS,
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
I WANT TO BE MRS. WONDERFUL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I WANT TO MAKE --
YOU DO NOT WANT TO BE
MRS. WONDERFUL.
MAYBE I TOOK IT TOO FAR.
OH, I LOVE THAT.
RACHEL,
YOU'RE AUTHENTIC.
YOU'RE SELLING SOMETHING
THAT YOU WOULD USE.
IT'S A VERY AUTHENTIC --
AND THAT'S WHAT
GREAT BRANDS ARE.
HEY, ROBERT, ARE YOU GONNA
MAKE HER AN OFFER?
YEAH,
I'M GONNA MAKE AN OFFER.
ALL RIGHT. I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $200,000 FOR 20%.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW, RACHEL,
I'VE GOT MULTIPLE COMPANIES NOW
INVOLVED WITH YOUNG FAMILIES,
AROUND WEDDINGS, ENGAGEMENTS --
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF USERS.
IT'S CALLED THE
SOMETHING WONDERFUL PLATFORM.
WE PUSH CUSTOMERS
AT A ZERO COST BASE
TO EACH OTHER.
I THINK YOU COULD
FIT NICELY IN IT
BECAUSE SO MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE CHILDREN.
SO I LIKE IT
FOR MY PORTFOLIO.
BUT I DON'T LIKE
THE RETAIL BUSINESS VERY MUCH.
OKAY. COOL.
AND SO I HAVE
A PLATFORM FOR YOU,
I'VE GOT LOGISTICS FOR YOU,
I'VE GOT --
DO YOU HAVE AN OFFER
FOR HER?
ALL RIGHT,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
FOR 20%.
'CAUSE I THINK --
Greiner: WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT ROBERT OFFERED YOU.
THIS IS BASICALLY WORTH
ONE-TIME SALES.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA GET TO
$1 MILLION IN SALES.
YEAH, WE SHOULD GET TO
$1 MILLION FOR SURE BY DECEMBER.
I DON'T DOUBT THAT AT ALL.
SPEAKING OF
PORTFOLIO COMPANIES,
WE HAVE A COMPANY
CALLED TIPSY ELVES.
GREAT GUYS. THEY WERE DOING
$600,000 A YEAR.
I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW MANY CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
OVER THREE YEARS ABOUT GOING
THIS WAY, ABOUT GOING THAT WAY.
YEAH.
THREE YEARS LATER,
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE?
WE'RE AN ONLINE COMPANY...
LOVE IT.
...THAT'LL DO OVER $15 MILLION
THIS YEAR.
WE'VE EXPANDED
THE PRODUCT LINE
BUT ALWAYS STAY TRUE
TO THE CORE.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
GOING DOWN KEVIN'S ROUTE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE ELIMINATED.
BUT THE SOMETHING WONDERFUL
PLATFORM
HAS HALF A BILLION IN SALES,
$500 MILLION THROUGH IT.
John: WELL --
THIS IS NOTHING.
WHILE THEY SQUABBLE,
I'M INTERESTED.
I LIKE THIS.
♪♪
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
RACHEL HAS TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE
FOR HER CHILDREN'S
CLOTHING BRAND, RAGS TO RACHES.
BUT DAYMOND
ALSO SEEMS INTERESTED.
John: I'M INTERESTED.
I LIKE THIS.
I KIND OF DISAGREE
WITH THE OTHER GUYS
ABOUT THE RETAIL STRATEGY.
I BELIEVE YOU NEED
TO TAKE THAT COMPETITOR
OUT OF THE MARKET
BY LICENSING
MASS-MARKET DIFFERENT-LEVEL
GOODS TO THAT COMPETITOR
SO THEY CAN THEN NOT KNOCK YOU
OFF AND THEY CAN --
KILLS YOUR BRAND.
THEY CAN PROTECT YOU
SO YOU CAN DO
THE HIGHER-END, ONLINE SALES
AND THEY DO
THE MASS MARKET
SO THAT NOW YOU'VE GOT
BOTH COVERED.
YOU'RE GETTING A LITTLE PIECE
OF THIS AND A LOT OF THAT.
SO YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING
KNOCK OFF MYSELF.
BASICALLY
KNOCK OFF YOURSELF.
THEN YOU HAVE TO SUPPORT
TWO BRANDS.
SO, SHE'S A YEAR
IN BUSINESS,
SHE'S GONNA START
ANOTHER BRAND?
THAT'S NOT SO GREAT.
YEAH. PEOPLE DO IT
ALL THE TIME.
WHO I'M GONNA TAKE YOU TO
IS GONNA HAVE 80 LICENSES
TO THROW ON THERE IMMEDIATELY,
AND THEN YOU MAKE MONEY.
SO LET'S HOPE THAT THEY GET
UP TO $50 MILLION A YEAR,
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, WE'RE MAKING
10% OFF THAT $50 MILLION.
SO, I'M GONNA OFFER YOU
THE SAME
WITH AN INTENTION
TO GO LICENSE A SUB-BRAND.
OKAY.
$200,000 FOR 20%.
WELL, YOU'VE GOT
THREE OFFERS ON THE TABLE.
YEAH.
HERE'S THE DEAL --
LIKE, ROBERT, TIPSY ELVES,
I'VE FOLLOWED THAT,
AND I'VE SEEN THE GROWTH,
AND I LOVE
THAT THEY ARE ONLINE.
IT SEEMS SIMPLE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE GONNA
COME IN AND WANT TO COPY.
I'D RATHER COPY MYSELF
AND MAKE CLOTHES --
THEY'RE GONNA CRANK IT OUT
NO MATTER WHAT,
SO EITHER
WE'RE GONNA MAKE MONEY
OFF THEM CRANKING IT OUT
OR NOT.
Herjavec:
NO, THAT'S SO NOT TRUE.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO CONTROL
YOUR INVENTORY COSTS.
ANYBODY CAN ALWAYS
KNOCK OFF ANYTHING.
RIGHT.
YOU DON'T HAVE SOMETHING
PROPRIETARY.
WHEN YOU CREATE THE BRAND
THAT YOU CAN
AND YOU GET TO $20 MILLION
AND $50 MILLION,
YOU CAN JUST
LICENSE YOUR NAME.
YOU'RE NOT THERE TODAY.
ROBERT, THEY'RE NOT PUTTING --
IT DOESN'T WORK.
THEY'RE NOT PUTTING
THE NAME ON --
YOU'RE NOT PUTTING
RAGS TO RACHES ON IT.
BUT WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA LICENSE?
A JUMPER
WITH AN ELASTIC BAND?
IF SOMEBODY WANTED
TO LICENSE THAT TODAY --
YEAH,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT --
THE BIG BOYS AND GIRLS
ARE DOING THAT NOW.
WILL SHE MAKE MONEY
OFF OF THAT?
LISTEN, I'VE DONE THIS WITH
30 DIFFERENT APPAREL COMPANIES.
RACHEL,
IT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
THEY'RE TALKING
WITH LIMITED UNDERSTANDING
BECAUSE THEY DID
ONE OR TWO.
LORI, ARE WE GONNA
HEAR FROM YOU OR NOT?
WHILE WE'RE STILL YOUNG?
LORI,
YOU DON'T HAVE AN OFFER?
I WOULD OFFER YOU SOMETHING
THAT'S JUST THE SAME AS DAYMOND,
BUT DAYMOND'S GREAT
AT DOING THAT.
THAT'S WHY I'M NOT
GOING TO MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
BUT I WISH YOU GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU, LORI.
OKAY. YOU GOT
THREE SHARKS INTERESTED.
THE OFFERS ARE IDENTICAL.
YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION.
ROBERT, ARE YOU WILLING TO
GO DOWN TO 15% FOR $200,000?
DO WE HAVE A DEAL
IF I DO?
OR ARE YOU GONNA CONTINUE
NEGOTIATING?
YOUR WHOLE BUSINESS IS WORTH
THE DIFFERENCE OF 5%?
NO.
THAT'S WHAT
THE PARTNER IS WORTH?
DOES IT REALLY MAKE
THAT BIG A DIFFERENCE, 5%?
MAYBE NOT, BUT --
RACHEL,
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
IF I GO DOWN TO 15%,
DO WE HAVE A DEAL?
DO YOU WANT A PARTNER
WHO IS NOT THAT VESTED IN IT?
ROBERT, WE HAVE A DEAL.
DONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU!
GOOD JOB!
THANK YOU, GUYS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
[ SQUEALS ]
I JUST CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE
THAT I STARTED TOTALLY BROKE,
SELLING MY KIDS' HAND-ME-DOWNS,
AND A LITTLE OVER A YEAR,
AND I'M HERE AS A MOM
WITH THREE YOUNG BOYS,
AND I MADE THIS WORK,
AND I MADE MY COMPANY A SUCCESS,
AND I'M SO PROUD OF MYSELF
AND MY FAMILY.